Nestor's had a policy debate on the
insolvency directive Sinister's are
positively inclined towards the
objectives of this proposal but of
course also signaled for flexibility we
had an exchange of views on best
practices and cooperation on the
protection of children in migration
which we deem requires particular
attention given the great vulnerability
of children today comes reach the
political agreement on the European
public prosecutor's office as a good day
for justice in Europe and back bad day
for criminals I'm also satisfied with
the result of the discussion on supply
of digital contents today's decision
clears the way for the discussions with
the European Parliament with the aim of
reaching agreement during the Estonian
presidencies connected with the Digital
Agenda we also spoke about the way
forward to combat hate speech online I
received quite strong mandate from the
Member States to continue to improve the
functioning of the code of conduct which
we agreed on with the pig for IT
providers last year to enlarge the scope
of the companies involved to test
whether this measure is decreasing the
appearance of hate speech and hatred
online